All right, so because of our vacation last week,
it's been almost two full weeks since we did
our last covid update cases, hospitalizations,
deaths, vaccinations. And I think while there's
still caution, I would characterize today's report
as good news compared to what we were seeing two
weeks ago. It did look for a little bit. There are
a couple of weeks ago, like we might be seeing a
pretty bad turn around with cases first leveling
off and even climbing slightly for about seven
to 10 days. And there were concerns about are we
heading towards a fourth wave or a fourth spike?
That uptick in cases has now reversed. In
some states, they're still spiking. And we'll
talk about why. But the cases are coming back
down. Deaths continue down, vaccinations have
dramatically accelerated. And I believe after
looking at the data, talking to a few doctors
yesterday and today and just looking at what Dr.
Fauci said recently as well, I believe we are on
the path to a very good situation by Memorial
Day, which is May 31st, the last day of May,
right around eight weeks from today. So let's
dig right into the data. Cases, you might recall
peaked at two hundred fifty six thousand a day
back in mid-January and started to decline,
bottoming out in the middle of March, around
55000 per day. But by the time our break started,
the cases had actually trickled back up to about
sixty eight thousand a day, up from 55 to 60 8-K.
And that's when the fourth wave discussion
started. The cause of that uptick appears to be a
combination of unvaccinated people going wild. If
you look at, for example, who's getting the virus
lately, it is more and more younger people getting
the virus not yet vaccinated, but acting as if
we've reached herd immunity, combined with
a more contagious British variant, which is
essentially dominant in some places. Michigan
is one place where we've seen a lot of that.
The Northeast is another place. It appears as
though we may not be on the way up because, again,
cases are starting to decline from that six to
eight K pop down to about 60 for now. That's a
small change. It's not totally obvious that
we're on the way back down, but at least
we're not continuing to see an increase. And if
vaccination continues to accelerate, we should see
substantial case declines over the next eight
weeks. And I'll tell you why a little bit later.
In terms of deaths, the strategy of vaccinating
the most likely to die if they get the virus after
doing health care workers, of course, is working
even as cases leveled out. And we said, well,
you know, deaths are on a three week delay from
cases. We may see deaths level out. They didn't.
Deaths have continued down the entire time. You
might remember they peaked at nearly 3500 per day,
more than a 9/11 a day in January. They went
below 3000 a day in the first week of February,
below 2000 today, around February 20th, below
1000 today, in that fourth week of March and now
down to just a hair. Over 800 deaths are still
horrifying. Still a tragic number, but one that
is now down about 77 percent from its peak in late
January. This should continue because cases aside,
even against the variants, the vaccines are nearly
one hundred percent effective at preventing death.
Vaccination over the weekend, the US had
consecutive days with four million vaccines
per day. We are now averaging just over three
million doses per day. This means that every day
roughly one percent of the US population is
getting a shot. Now, it's not. One percent is
being fully vaccinated each day. A lot of those
are two dose regimens. So still one percent of
the US population is now getting a shot every
day. The reason we know this will pay off
in about six to eight weeks is we look at Israeli
data. Israel has now vaccinated more than 55
percent of its population. They are basically
wide open. Passover was almost a completely normal
Passover with gatherings and everything and cases
and hospitalizations, serious covid deaths are
all down, down, down dramatically. We have the
chart up on the screen for our video audience.
It looks very, very good. Now, then we get to. But
but but David, what about those variants? Yeah,
the variants are concerning eight, nine, 10 months
from now, maybe even six to eight. We may be
seeing new booster vaccines dialed in for these
variants. The current vaccines work pretty well
against the variants. They work less well, but
they work pretty well and they are almost as
effective at preventing serious covid and death in
almost every case. Here's a graphic from Dr. Eric
Topol, who we've interviewed on the program.
I highly recommend following him on Twitter
about the variance against the UK variant, a very
modest reduction in vaccine efficacy against the
South African variant. A little more reduction. We
don't yet have real world data about the Brazilian
variant, but that's the least prevalent variant in
the US and in vitro studies. Serum's studies show
that the vaccines still work against the Brazilian
variant, but we do have to keep vaccinating
faster. It's a race. What will we what will happen
faster? These variants becoming predominant or
vaccination? Israel is predominantly the
British variant, and they are, as I showed you,
completely dominating this. Joe Biden today
expected to announce another major advance in
full vaccination eligibility. Remember, Joe Biden
about a month ago said May 1st, I want every state
making everybody eligible today. And it may
happen before you listen to today's show. Joe
Biden expected to announce that he's moving that
up by a couple of weeks, April 19th. Now there
will be a full vaccine eligibility. All good news
going in the right direction. Let's keep going.